[Musique]
c'est magique ce qui se passe ici vous
avez qu en tête le tout on est pris dans
l'ambiance
comme quoi en gros ne crois pas on est
pris dedans quand on arrive on voit tout
ça et on est pris dedans
c'est une croyance c'est la sainte
vierge en touche mais comme je voulais
dit c'est magique
il n'ya pas d'autre mot à dire
l'homme n'est pas miraculeuse mais elle
sait le sait la fois que j'aimais dedans
et quand même mari a dit à bernadette
aller boire et vous il avait je rapporte
de l'eau pour ma famille pour payer pour
qu'ils reçoivent de l'eau pour pour les
personnes âgées aussi de ma famille pour
qu'ils peuvent pas se déplacer et c'est
tout je sais qu'elle peut faire des
miracles alors je leur donne pour eux
mêmes pour la guérison
on y croit quoi l'eau bénite qui fait
des je crois pas beaucoup aux miracles
quand méme pas quand je reverrai 1
j'y croirai